forests have always been a coveted
resource for humans they also tend to be
quite dark and spooky maybe that's why
there's a long history of humans
inventing monsters whose real purpose is
protecting the forest in parts of Russia
the shape-shifting Lei guards the forest
against ill-intentioned hunters and
Harvesters a lushi helps you out of a
tight spot but only if you've given an
appropriate sacrifice and avoided
disturbing the flora and fauna and if
you don't they'll trick you into harming
yourself then there's a poisonous umby
tree or dead man's tree a toxic plant in
South Africa according to the zul
people's Legend the temperamental tree
takes nutrients from the poison corpses
littering the soil around it the tree's
valuable fruit can only be collected
after it has already fallen to the
ground a handy device for sustainable
harvesting and let's not forget the map
in guari a giant Amazonian monster this
creature will literally eat malicious
trespassers chowing down on its victims
slowly sometimes with the giant mouth in
the center of its stomach the moral of
all these Tales don't be greedy with
natural resources and always keep your
eyes peeled in the forest or a monster
will get you